[Music]
the nine remaining years of this decade
could well be the turning point in
humanity's bid to stave off
the most devastating effects of climate
change with only a handful of exceptions
every government in the world has
pledged to keep global temperatures
to well below two degrees of
pre-industrial levels
but to do that radical action and
cooperation between countries the type
of which has never yet been seen in
human history
is going to be needed starting now
quite simply if the necessary steps
aren't taken by 2030
it'll be too late so can it be done
can it be done fairly what role will
europe play
and crucially how will it be financed at
a time when both governments
and the private sector are reeling from
the economic hurricane
of the worst pandemic for a century or
more
over the next four hours we'll be
exploring practical solutions to these
questions
with a selection of the most important
people anywhere in the world involved in
making these decisions
and seeing them turned into action
coming up we have ursula van der lion
president of the european commission
christine lagarde is president of the
european central bank
we'll hear from christolina gorgieva
managing director of the imf
and amila mohammed deputy secretary
general of the united nations
werner hoyer is the president of the
european investment bank
france timmerman's executive vice
president of the european commission
michael bloomberg the u.n secretary
general's envoy for climate ambition and
solutions
oliver baiter chairman of the board of
management of allianz sc
and john kerry the special presidential
envoy for climate
in the new biden administration
quite a lineup and that is just the
redacted version
now don't be intimidated you don't need
to run a major international institution
to be part of today's events
it's also vital that you the audience
watching are part of the conversation
too so please do get involved using the
hashtag
investing in climate action but first
let's remind ourselves of what's at
stake
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things
not because they are easy but because
they are hard
[Music]
[Music]
this is europe's man on the moon moment
so
we'll be taking a solution-based lens to
the issue over three sessions today
following opening remarks from the
european commission and european
investment bank
we'll begin with session one getting our
hands green
a look at the political action needed
across the continent
then i'll be handing over to joe coburn
at 3 40
cet for session 2 a new green boom
which will drill deep into how the flows
of finance around the world
can be aligned with climate goals then
in our final session at 5 cet climate
action goes global
i'll join joe to explore how the world
can work together
and if it can work together but to begin
the day's events
i'm delighted to be joined live from
brussels by european commission
president ursula van der lyon
uh but first of all we've got a
technical issue that we do need to sort
out
so bear with us for a couple of seconds
and we'll come straight back to
the president of the european commission
uh in a few seconds time
as soon as we get those lines up i'm
afraid we are living in these
age of zoom etc
okay for those of you who are staying
with us we're sorting out some streaming
issues here in our links to brussels
as soon as we sort that out we become
back to you in vision
and we'll bring you the president of the
european commission ursula von der line
so please
bear with us a little bit longer thank
you
i thank you for bearing with us there we
now have our link to brussels fully
established so i'm going to hand
straight over to the president of the
european commission
ursula von der lion president
thank you so much sean and distinguished
guests ladies and gentlemen
it's a pleasure to welcome you to this
conference on the
make or break decade a make or break
decade for climate action
and indeed the next 10 years must be a
turning point
first and foremost for global co2
emissions
today global emissions are still rising
and this has to change as a matter of
urgency
europe has decided to cut emissions by
at least 55
already in the coming decade this is to
do our part
and to show the way we must act now
before it's too late and there's another
factor
that can make a difference between make
or break
it's how we think about climate action
climate action is not only a necessity
it is also the greatest economic
opportunity of our time
we are on the edge of a transformation
similar to the digital revolution of 40
years ago
in the 1980s personal computers
mobile phones and the world wide web saw
the light
in a matter of a few years businesses
and consumers started asking for new
services and products
new markets were created from nothing
we started to desire things that didn't
even exist before
and a similar transformation is now
happening again
europeans are discovering new needs from
clean mobility
to local organic food researchers are
testing new clean technologies
and investors are seeking green
investment opportunities
in a matter of a few years we will
change
the way we move the way we eat the way
we produce
you name it so the question is
are we ready to catch this opportunity
i believe we are just one example
55 of the world's new hydrogen projects
are in europe clean hydrogen
is a textbook means towards our goal of
climate neutrality
and europe is investing in it more than
any other global power
european business and investors
understand the change that is about to
happen
and they want to be the drivers of this
change
they want to build europe's leadership
in the markets of tomorrow
and this is a central goal of the
european green deal together with
fighting climate change
the european green deal is our road map
towards climate neutrality but it is
also
and crucially our new growth strategy
a strategy to make europe more
competitive on tomorrow's green markets
thus we are supporting the european
green deal goals
with an unprecedented wave of public
investment
over 280 billion euros
from our recovery plan next generation
eu
will finance climate action
and then we have the new european budget
the new projects of european interest
and the impressive support from the
european investment bank
and let me spend just a few words to say
how glad i am for this joint
event with the eib
the eib is redefining the role
of a multilateral development bank
becoming europe's climate bank
and you are showing the way forward for
the critical decade and
i must say i'm really proud of that
so public investment is coming
there are now three crucial tasks
that we will have to tackle in the
immediate future first
we must ensure the quality of our
investment
we should try and maximize the impact of
every euro we spend in terms of
environmental impact but also of job
creation and
innovation second
we must work to mobilize as much private
investment as possible
we need an investment revolution that
goes well beyond the public sector
to catch the green opportunities of the
2020s
and third we must look beyond europe's
borders too
we must explore new forms of global
cooperation on green finance
towards a climate friendly economy
europe will be the first climate neutral
continent
but we don't want it to be the only one
and i want this decade to be the roaring
twenties of climate action and climate
investment
europe must lead this change
it's our last chance to stop climate
change
and it's a once in a generation
opportunity
to become global leaders in the economy
of the future
so i wish you a fruitful conference
and i very much thank you for your
attention
president van der lyon thank you very
much i'm now equally delighted to bring
you the european investment bank
president
vernon hoyer speaking to us live from
luxembourg
ladies and gentlemen colleagues and
friends
i'm delighted to welcome you on behalf
of the european investment bank to this
important conference
a special welcome to our co-organizer of
the european commission under the
leadership of oslo thunder line
and her executive vice presidents by liz
dombroskis and franz timmermans
thank you very much